(cop show music)
- [Tape Recorder] Welcome
to Synergizing You,
an eight step program to self--
Chance, you totally rule.
Your hair rules,
your jacket rules.
Theresa's a bitch, no
one can touch you man.
- Suck it cops!
- Come on Moses!
- Just go.
- Come on, he's getting away!
- Just go, I'll
catch up with you.
- Seriously?
- Just go.
Dehydrated.
Leg cramp, cramp.
Chance, leg out.
Chance, I need you!
(gunshots)
- You know, I
really could've used
your help back there, Moses.
- No you did great.
- You're right I did great.
I jumped off a roof,
tackled him through
the window of a guest
house, I'd have to say
that's better than great.
That's pretty frickin'
awesome I'd have to say.
- It was more like
a garden shed, dude.
- There was a window
in it, you shut up.
My point is Moses, what's the
point of having a partner,
if you're not gonna get my back?
I mean what if he
had a gun, huh?
- I didn't have a gun,
I don't have a gun,
because I traded it
for meth, ya'll, ha ha!
- Shut your mouth, get in
there, watch your head.
- Watch your head.
Hey no offense guys,
if I did have a gun,
woulda shot ya both.
- Listen, you have the
right to remain silent,
I suggest you use it,
we record everything
that happens back there.
- I'm just being
honest, for the record.
Woulda shot ya both
through the teeth.
- For the record,
shut your mouth.
Moses, I gotta tell
ya this, alright.
You need to lose weight.
- Okay, I may have gained
a few extra pounds,
but I still get the job done.
- Wait, you literally just
didn't get the job done
because you are fat.
- Hey, you were high on meth.
He was high on meth so he
was probably running faster.
- That's not how it works.
- I believe that is how
it works, I read a--
- Well I do meth all the time,
and that's not how it works.
- Okay, well what if
you did have a gun,
what if he had a gun?
- I didn't have a gun.
- Well what, hypothetically,
what if he had a gun?
- Well hypothetically
anything could've happened.
- I could have had a chainsaw.
- You didn't even have a gun.
- Ooh, chainsaw's
pretty easy to get.
I was just in a shed...
- Aw, forget about the chainsaw,
that's not believable enough.
Let's say you didn't
speak English.
- Where ya going with that?
- Let's say I tackle ya in
the dirt and I got your face
and I'm rubbing it and I
say "Don't get up, fucker,"
and you didn't understand
the translation.
- Okay, yeah yeah, I'm with ya.
- And what if you
were running away
and you jumped over a
fence, I mean there's
a lot of fences
in this town now.
- So hypothetically let's
say my partner needed me,
because there's a
non-English speaking,
chainsaw-wielding maniac--
- Wait, wait, do I have
a chainsaw, or a gun?
- You don't have a chainsaw,
you still have a gun,
hypothetically.
- Okay, whatever.
Hypothetically, let's say your
partner was being, um, uh,
a jag off,
- Ooooh.
jag off, about a
really sensitive issue
that you have, and you
couldn't do your job
because he wasn't being
supportive enough.
- Bullshit, there's no way you
could run down this asshole!
- See, that's what I'm talking
about, he's so negative.
- Yeah, don't call
me an asshole, man,
I thought we were
on the same page.
- I thought we were
on the same team.
- We're on the same team.
I'm on the same page
with him though.
- You're right, I haven't been
so supportive lately Moses,
and I'm gonna change that
right now, you know why?
Because I believe in you.
- That's weird, stop it.
- No it's not weird.
I believe in you, I
believe you can catch
this asshole, jag
off, meth head.
- I can.
- I know you can.
- You know I can.
You know I can.
- I know you can catch him,
I know you can catch him,
I think you should go
catch him right now.
You believe you can run
down this meth head?
Then run down this meth head,
he's gonna run your butt down,
let's do this, come
on Moses, here we go.
[Meth Head] Wait
what are we doing?
No, let's not.
- Come on, get out.
Come on, out ya go.
Okay Moses, are you ready?
- Yeah, are you ready
to be totally wrong?
- Okay, go.
- Well wait, you guys said
you're recording all this right,
because if I'm
gonna get a beating
I at least wanna have it
on my YouTube channel.
- Seriously dude?
Get the fuck out of here.
- Three, two, one, got his ass!
- Go Moses!
Run, little trooper!
Run like an eagle,
come on Moses!
Moses?
Come on man, seriously?
(puking)
(Moses sobbing)